Disney movies have more than their fair share
of cool hidden Easter eggs.
They also happen to have lots of weird, controversial,
and just plain creepy secrets and moments
that only someone who's truly obsessed would
bother compiling into a single list.
So here we go.
The Lion King's sex dust
Remember watching 1994's The Lion King as
a kid, being enthralled by Simba's struggle
to face his fears and confront his villainous
uncle, and being totally distracted by the
sudden and unmistakable appearance of SEX?
No?
Well, tell that to the American Life League,
the conservative group that in 1995 claimed
the word "SEX" is spelled out in a dust cloud
in the sky after Simba flops down onto a ledge.
But Tom Sito, one of the movie's animators,
has since explained that the dust cloud actually
spells out "SFX," or "special effects," a
kind of a signature inserted into one frame
of animation by Disney's effects team.
And you know?
That's probably true.
Because slipping a word as tame as "sex" into
a single frame of an animated movie is unbelievably
lame.
If an animator really wanted to mess with
people's heads, he'd put in something way
more risque.
Like "butt," or "winkle," or something.
Or maybe he'd just throw in a picture of a
topless woman.
The Rescuers' topless woman picture
In 1999, Disney made a surprising announcement,
saying it was going to recall 3.4 million
copies of its 1977 animated film, The Rescuers,
just three days after the movie's second release
on home video.
The reason?
That was even more shocking: hidden within
two frames of the movie was an inexplicable
photo of a naked lady.
Apparently, sometime between the film's completion
and its debut in theaters, someone in the
distribution chain slipped the image in, unbeknownst
to Disney, or really anyone.
The image probably would never have been discovered
at all if it weren't for improvements in video
technology that allowed people to freeze the
movie and find its secret shame.
Nearly three months later, The Rescuers was
released once again, this time without the
nudie pics.
Meanwhile, copies of the movie that escaped
the recall are fetching big bucks on ebay,
commanding whopping prices between, uh, four
and eleven dollars.
Never mind.
Anyway, this isn't really that bad.
It's not like one of the animators drew a
woman not wearing any underpants.
Jessica Rabbit isn't wearing underpants
In 1988's Who Framed Roger Rabbit?, femme
fatale Jessica Rabbit has an infamous line:
"I'm not bad, I'm just drawn that way."
As it turns out, that was a little truer than
anyone could've guessed.
Just as the video release of The Rescuers
revealed a hidden controversy, so too did
the Laserdisc release of Roger Rabbit.
When Jessica and Eddie Valiant get into a
car crash, they're both thrown from their
cab.
For the briefest of moments, only about a
frame or two, viewers can see that the animators
declined to draw any definitive underwear
between Jessica's legs.
So is a missing line of paint enough to cause
a panic?
Is it creepy that Mickey owns a dog and is
friends with Goofy, who is also a dog?
The answer to both questions is "yes."
Reports from the time said that retailers
sold out of the laserdisc for the movie one
day after initial news of the missing undies
hit the media back in 1994.
Fortunately for fans of decency everywhere,
the missing underthings were inserted for
the movie's DVD release.
But come on, this was clearly much ado about
nothing.
Nobody could actually see any genitals or
anything.
All the genitals in The Little Mermaid
The Little Mermaid from 1989 doesn't seem
like it'd have much room for any naughty bits,
especially since all of the movie's undersea
denizens have, well, people parts on the top
and fish parts on the bottom.
But when the evil Ursula tries to trick Eric
into marrying her, the minister officiating
the wedding seems to be...excited by the impending
nuptials.
Disney's Tom Sito said that what looks like
the guy's little minister is actually his
knee.
Then, on the cover art of the original home
video release for The Little Mermaid, many
people have found what sure does look like
an important part of the male anatomy hidden
in a spire on an underwater castle.
One report claims that the artist, who was
a freelance illustrator working on the cover
and not a Disney employee, was simply in a
rush to finish the cover art and stayed up
late the night before the deadline to finish
the job.
In the end, the minister seems to have survived
various video releases untouched, while the
cover image had its conspicuous spire cut.
Seriously, though, people are making mountains
out of molehills here.
It'd make sense to get upset only if there
were something truly objectionable in these
Disney movies...something like a never-ending
parade of stereotypes and blatant racism.
The parade of stereotypes and blatant racism
in Disney movies
Okay!
So, a whole lot of Disney movies were made
and released during a time in America where
concepts like "ethnic and racial sensitivity"
or "political correctness" weren't really,
like, things.
As a result, some of these flicks have aged
pretty horribly due to the inclusion of characters
that are unavoidably offensive by today's
standards.
In fact, one Disney movie is so entirely racist
that it will simply never be released on video.
Ever.
Where to start?
In Dumbo from 1941, the baby elephant encounters
a group of crows, who've since been identified
as racist caricatures of African-Americans.
Case in point: the leader of that group was
originally called "Jim Crow" in the script.
However, some have pointed out that the crows
are actually positive, since they're some
of the only characters who help Dumbo and
identify with his outsider status.
Too bad the rest of these examples aren't
quite so easy to justify.
The original cut of Fantasia from 1940 features
a sequence based on Beethoven's Pastoral Symphony,
which features centaurs and other Greek mythical
creatures getting ready for a feast.
Included in that sequence are two servant
centaurs named Sunflower and Otika who are
clearly modeled after African-American stereotypes.
They've been cut from subsequent releases
of
the movie.
Then there's the highly inappropriate depiction
of Native Americans in 1953's Peter Pan, in
which Tiger Lily and her people act in ridiculously
wild ways and speak in broken English, and
are repeatedly referred to as "savages."
And Lady and the Tramp from 1955 features
an extended sequence depicting evil Siamese
cats with thick accents and plenty of other
offensive Asian stereotypes.
The worst offender, though, is 1946's Song
of the South, a movie you may not even know
about, since it's never been released on video
in the United States.
You've definitely heard one of its tunes,
"Zip-a-Dee-Doo-Dah," which won the Academy
Award for Best Song in 1947.
But the movie's general reliance on black
stereotypes and racial caricatures have made
it what one critic calls "one of Hollywood's
most resiliently offensive racist texts."
Yikes.
Kind of makes all those wieners and ding-dongs
all over The Little Mermaid sound almost cute
now, huh?
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to see more
videos like the one you just saw.